canned cranberry sauce slaps it's Tangy
it's sweet it is basically as easy as
opening a
[Music]
can Okay but seriously why can that
sometimes be so hard it is my favorite
part of any Thanksgiving and Christmas
meal the only thing stopping me from
eating it like three times a day is that
it's kind of just like eating a bowl
full of jam it's pretty sweet at least
according to my very sensitive teeth but
I'm going to show you how to up your
canned cranberry game delivering more
flavor texture satiety and a little h
spot to tell your guest that it's
homemade canned cranberries in and we
toss in a bunch of diced pears not only
do pears or apples add fiber flavor and
crunch but they help to stretch out the
added sugar proportion finally I like
things a little more textured so I add
some crushed
pecans finished with a little orange
desk for that yes of course it's
homemade VI and there you go a cranberry
apple pecan relish that you can and will
eat all year round M so
good